les européens demandent que les otages
soient rendus mais aucune sanctions
décidées contre l'iran à l'assemblée
demain une nouvelle législation sur le
viol dans cette édition le témoignage
d'une victime
edmond maire le secrétaire général de la
cfdt est l'invité de ce journal
voilà monsieur bonsoir vous allez les
voir depuis cinq jours nous vous en
parlions sans malheureusement pouvoir
vous les montre et voici donc ces
milliers de cubains qui se sont réfugiés
dans les jardins de l'ambassade du pérou
à la havane pour réclamer le droit de
partir de leur pays ces documents sont
encore très fragmentaire il s'agit
seulement de trois photos qui donnent
malgré tout une idée de l'atmosphère qui
règne sur les lieux mais paul nahon ce
sera bientôt la catastrophe à
l'ambassade du pérou l'atmosphère frôle
l'hystérie
on craint des explosions de violence et
que les premières victimes soient des
enfants et des nourrissons et l'on
craint aussi les risques d'épidémies dix
mille personnes entassées sur 2000
mètres carrés
les autorités ont bien installer des
latrines à l'extérieur de l'ambassade
mais les réfugiés préfèrent ne pas se
déplacer de peur d'être pris par les
garde cubain et la pelouse est jonché
d'excréments
la plupart des réfugiés refuse
maintenant de s'alimenter il estime ne
rien devoir accepter du gouvernement
cubain à l'extérieur de l'ambassade le
gouvernement à organiser des contre
manifestations à l'appel du parti
communiste cubain
malheureusement la situation risque de
s'éterniser car à lima les pays du pacte
en daim n'ont pas réussi ce soir à se
mettre d'accord pour recevoir dans
l'immédiat les réfugiés cependant des
avions se tiennent prêts à s'envoler à
tout moment pour la havane afin
d'organiser un véritable pont aérien
entre l'île et le continent
je fais non merde vous n'êtes pas venus
là pour parler de cuba mais je vous avez
regardé ce document avec beaucoup
d'attention quelle réflexion cela vous
inspire-t-il
et bien si vous voulez le fait que le
socialiste est pas seulement un syndrome
besoins sociaux c'est aussi une
atmosphère de liberté
c'est ce qu'on a toujours pensé cuba a
des grandes réussites dans l'éducation
dans aussi la non seulement de la santé
dans le domaine de la santé par contre
en donnant même des difficultés
économiques
l'encadrement par quartier le système
bureaucratique pèse et finalement
lorsqu'il ya un espace qui s'ouvre et
une partie de la population vote avec
ses pieds ce qu'elle ne peut pas
exprimer d'une façon courante dans la
vie publique et politique
elle exprime en souhaitant donner est ce
que cette ombre de cuba va planer comme
celle de kaboul ou encore de la sphère
sakharov entre vos rapports avec par
exemple la cgt et les formes d'autres
formations de gauche
on croit qu'on ne peut pas du tout
mettre sur le même plan si vous voulez
les problèmes de l'afghanistan et ceux
de cuba
je l'aï plutôt faire preuve à part un
parallèle avec la situation elle était
placée cuba depuis 20 ans en raison de
la politique américaine parce qu'au
total il y a eu des je crois une
déviation à l'intérieur du régime cubain
mais quand même le blocus américain a
causé je crois des conséquences graves
sur l'évolution de ce régime
et lorsque l'on voit que ce blocus
actuellement américains s'appliquent à
l'iran on peut au contraire penser que
malheureusement l'expérience de fer pas
toujours bien sûr mais c'est tout de
même encore un mii socialiste qui
s'effondre vous savez je crois qu'il ya
eu un moment donné à 8 du socialisme
dont un tiers monde réalisé ici ou là
avant cuba c'était dans d'autres pays
serait-il vietnam un moment je crois
qu'au total on ne peut penser social
disque d'abord fondamentalement fondé
sur la liberté ce que je disais tout à
l'heure
et de ce point de vue le socialiste
reste à construire s'il arrive quoi que
ce soit aux otages de l'ambassade
américaine de téhéran
les états unis interviendront
militairement c'est ce qu'a rappelé
aujourd'hui un haut fonctionnaire du
département d'état américain
en réponse aux menaces des étudiants
islamiques justement en cas
l'intervention américaine en iran
l'américain qui sont préoccupés par la
recherche d'une solidarité effective de
leurs alliés notamment européens et qui
juste
aujourd'hui à lisbonne ont décidé
d'effectuer une démarche européenne
auprès de l'iran afin de leur demander
la libération des otages bernard
et les européens soulignent dans leur
déclaration que l'attitude actuelle de
téhéran est inacceptable les neufs n'ont
pas adopté de position définitive celle
ci dépendra du résultat des démarches
effectuées par leurs ambassadeurs en
poste à téhéran
néanmoins les américains ont déjà fait
savoir qu'ils étaient assez satisfait à
washington où l'administration carter
n'a pas ménagé ses efforts depuis
plusieurs jours on estime que les
européens ne peuvent pas en faire plus
pour le moment on est sans doute encore
loin des mesures de rétorsion réclamée
par la maison blanche
mais les américains espèrent que la
démarche européenne pèse ravaux poids
attire
il ya une petite contradiction
semble-t-il entre ce que disent certains
milieux gouvernementaux américains est
ce que vient de déclarer à l'instant le
président américain carter qui au cours
d'une conférence de presse à critiquer
sesia ses alliés leur a reproché leurs
contradictions et leur manque de soutien
dans la sphère iranienne ils demandent
en parlant des alliés sans les nommer
précisément a dit le président carter il
demande protection mais reculent devant
les obligations d'une alliance d'autres
encore at il ajouté demande la fermeté
la serti de la certitude tout en
exigeant en même temps de la souplesse
reste à savoir si moment où il a fait
ses critiques le président américain
était au courant de ce qui avait été
décidé par les européens à lisbonne et
puis toujours en relation avec la sphère
iranienne une autre dépêche qui vient
d'arriver à l'instant qui signalent les
mouvements d'unités de la flotte
iranienne dans le détroit d'ormuz c'est
ce qu'a indiqué ce soit la radio
iranienne france la participation des
salariés dans l'entreprise ne posent pas
simplement des problèmes entre syndicats
et employeurs elle en pose aussi au
niveau politique entre les formations de
la majorité actuelle qui vont devoir
voter le projet présenté par le
gouvernement
c'est pour tenter de réduire les
divergences entre le rpr et l'udf que
monsieur raymond barre avait réuni ce
matin les députés des deux groupes
daniel monsieur bart a réussi ce matin à
mettre de l'huile sur les rails du train
de la participation
les représentants du rpr et de l'udf
après une longue concertation à la table
de matignon ont tous reconnu qu'il
s'était mis d'accord sur l'essentiel
ceux du rpr ajoutant monsieur bart a
soutenu nos conceptions les wagons de
l'actionnariat et de la participation
des cadres au conseil d'administration
ou au conseil de surveillance devrait
donc arriver à bon port cela ne signifie
pas pour autant que tel ou tel député de
la majorité ne déposera pas un
amendement pour aller ou moins loin ou
plus vont être le texte initial mais le
projet ne devrait pas s'embourber
les deux rapporteurs monsieur hamel eu d
f delalande rpr constater ce soir quand
nos deux groupes travaillent ensemble
sérieusement et en temps voulu
ils aboutissent à une même conception
sur le plan économique et social
la durée du travail du temps le rapport
confié à monsieur giraudet doit
normalement sortir à la fin de ce mois
un homme est particulièrement attentif à
cet événement monsieur edmond maire
secrétaire confédéral de la cfdt pour
qui la réduction du temps de travail est
un objectif prioritaire que vous
attendez alors est ce que vous voulez
vraiment monsieur mer la reprise de
cette négociation
bien sûr mais permettez moi d'abord de
vous expliquer le plus simplement
possible où on en est quels sont les
problèmes
en fait il y en a quatre principaux le
premier nous voulons sept jours de congé
de plus pour les salariés ça peut faire
la 5ème semaine ou bien ils peuvent les
détacher le cnpf dit d'accord pour cinq
jours à condition qu'on ne demande pas
un seul jour de l'année y compris pour
maladie accidents du travail ou grève
monsieur giraudet d'après ce que nous
pouvons en pensez abandonnerait les
clauses de présence
ce qui sera donc positif deuxième point
la durée réelle hebdomadaire
actuellement elle est en france de deux
mille trois cent quatre heures maximum
nous voulons la réduire de cinq cent
vingt la ramener effectivement un 40
heures par semaine
en trois ans le cnpf non seulement ne
veut la réduire
et encore cac40 3 heures mais en
ajoutant des heures exceptionnelles
d'après ce que nous pouvons savoir
monsieur giraudet s'orienterait plutôt
vers 1900 heures par an c'est à dire en
gros entre quarante deux vers 42 eur
troisième problème clé les travaux
pénibles
sur ce point nous voulons deux heures
demain pour tous les salariés qui font
des travaux pénibles
ils sont plusieurs millions le cnpf ne
veut leur accorder qu'un tout petit
nombre
un jour ou deux de repos par an monsieur
giraudet serait d'après nos informations
favorables 1 ou 2 heures une ou deux
heures des réductions par semaine enfin
le quatrième - celui de la discussion
dans l'entreprise à l'international
parce qu'en fait
s'il y avait un accord national qui va
discuter pour aménager les horaires
créer des emplois des diverses
conséquences de cet accord
nous nous disons les syndicats le cnpf
dit la direction des entreprises tout
seul et monsieur giraudet nous ne
connaissons pas sur ce point ses
positions ce qui veut dire qu'au total
dans le blocage total de la position du
patronat tel que nous l'avons jusqu'ici
la reprise des discussions par monsieur
giraud dette s'il fait un rapport sur
les bases que nous avons cru comprendre
tout à l'heure ce serait effectivement
un prêt positif et ça permettrait à
notre avis une reprise des discussions
dans de bonnes conditions
bien maintenant qu'on vient voir les
bases sur lesquelles vous voulez
commencer à discuter est-ce que j'en
reviens à la fin de ma dès la première
question est ce que vous voulez vraiment
la reprise de cette négociation
mais je vais vous dire pour nous c'est
fondamental nous ne pouvons pas accepter
d'être traîné plus longtemps dans des
impasses
nous croyons même comprendre qu'en face
il y a des intentions électorales pour
faire traîner les choses
entré dans la période des
présidentielles ça permettrait paraît-il
de jouer avec l'opinion publique et
peut-être même de reprend m à nouveau
pour après les élections ce qui est
urgent tout de suite les problèmes
d'emploi sont elles l'état des relations
sociales sont tellement dégradées dans
ce pays qu à notre avis il faut
absolument un accord avant les vacances
nous ferons tout pour cela et nous
espérons que le gouvernement mettra tout
son droit non seulement dans que ce
rapport sorte mais pour qu'effectivement
il y à une négociation positive au plus
vite qui réglera pas tout mais qui sera
carrément d'avancé mais ces mères vous
parler de ce projet avec beaucoup de
fougue et de fermeté c'est parce que
c'est toute votre politique de
recentrage c'est-à-dire de négociations
concrètes qui est en jeu dans cette
affaire six à effet scellé vendredi
quelque à vous monsieur demain je vais
très très clairement c'est notre
politique d'action syndicale et de
négociation action ça des cas les
négociations car si l'action ça n'est
qu'un ne mène à rien à aucun résultat
un blocage total que peut-il se passer
d'autres que les révoltes que la tante
de grands soirs l'attend d'après demain
c'est plus syndicats qui est sur le
terrain c'est les forces politiques
c'est autre chose c'est la révolte dans
le pays c'est la déstabilisation de la
société donc à notre avis il est tout à
fait essentiel que l'action syndicale
marque des points qu'elle s'exerce
qu'elles se développent dans les
semaines à venir avant les branches et
les entreprises et qu'elles débouchent
avant les vacances sur la durée du
travail deux dernières questions
monsieur mer
réduction du temps de travail vous savez
vous semble-t-elle compatible avec les
forts que l'on demande actuellement à
l'économie et la compétition économique
à la nation
écoutez c'est évident vous entendez nos
cieux bahr parlait d'assainissement de
l'économie
vous entendez les patrons et vous les
voyez les chiffres les profits des
entreprises remonte
nous sommes dans une austérité à sens
unique mais réellement où tout le poids
de la crise porte sur les seuls salariés
les mesures limitées que nous proposons
réaliste permettrait quand même
d'alléger la peine des hommes de créer
des emplois ce n'est pas extraordinaire
peut-être mais ce serait au moins une
autre pente que celle dans laquelle nous
nous enfonçons une dernière question
monsieur le maire vous en êtes souvent
pris au parti politique on se souvient
de quelques unes de vos phrases en
regrettant leur absence des vrais débats
politiques du pays
en vous battant par ailleurs maintenant
avec la cgt sur le problème de
l'afghanistan où sur la sphère sakharov
est ce que vous ne l'emprunté pas le
même chemin
écoutez nous voulons écarter tout
préalable politique tout préalable
internationale à l'action syndicale nous
voulons réellement que sur les objectifs
précis immédiat c'est tout de même le
thème de vos désaccords
oui mais oui l'autre jour ici oui non le
thème du désaccord n'est pas bon pour la
cfdt il est absolument pas les problèmes
internationaux ça ce sont des accords
qui existent bombe à hydrogène
il ya plusieurs organisations syndicales
ça ne les empêche pas face à un patron
au cnpf de se mettre d'accord et d'agir
ensemble
voilà pourquoi nous voulons absolument
continuer une politique unitaire qui
existe d'ailleurs car même et un certain
louis ii je vais vous quand même vous
contredire parce que le défilé du 1er
mai va se passer à peu près aux quatre
coins de paris toutes les organisations
vont faire le défi est ce que ça vous
semble une image unitaire ce que nous
regrettons profondément démocrates ont
profondément nous pensons doute les
désaccords autres organisations
déploient une raison suffisante pour
qu'elle se séparait qu'elle se divisent
nous aurions souhaité que partout comme
nous l'avons demandé à toutes nos
organisations régionales il y a des 1er
mai unitaire
malheureusement ce ne sera pas possible
eh bien ma foi nous continuerons nos
efforts pour nous retrouver dans
l'action et au delà dans les premiers
mais futur monsieur non mais remercie
changé la notion est la signification de
l'acte qui constitue le viol le débat
s'ouvre demain à l'assemblée nationale
avec le projet de loi présenté par le
gouvernement
mais avant de détailler ce texte vous
propose d'écouter de regarder ce
témoignage
une jeune fille de 18 ans violée au mois
d'août dernier explique très simplement
ce que peut ressentir une femme violée
pourquoi souvent
c'est son cas ces femmes ne portent pas
plainte enfin les conséquences parfois
très grave très grave pardon et durable
d'un viol sur le comportement de ses
victimes un récit poignant recueillis
par denise beau être un exemple que nous
ne sommes pas allés chercher très loin
car dès viols il y en a plus souvent
qu'on ne le pense généralement
c'était un après midi il y avait
beaucoup de soleil survenait du cinéma
et une voiture s'est arrêtée près de moi
pour me demander un renseignement
je me suis approché il voulait savoir le
nom d'une rue et un moment je me suis
approché l'a ouvert la portière et
m'entraîner de force
voilà j'ai commencé je me rendais pas
tellement content de ce qui se passait
et arriver à un pavillon de cet arrêté
ma fait descendre
je suis descendu on a fait monter dans
son appartement j'ai commencé à me
débattre me rendant compte plus ou mois
ce qui allait se passer
il m'a commencé à me donner des coups
des gifles je suis j'ai été un petit peu
inconsciente
j'ai perdu conscience aussi bon il m'a
traîné de force chez lui arrivé chez lui
il a tout fermé à clé et là j'ai repris
conscience plus ou moins je me suis
rendu compte exactement de ce qui se
passait j'ai cherché à m'en aller
il m'a retenu j'ai voulu sauter par la
fenêtre vu que ce n'était pas très très
haut
et là il m'a il m'a tapée m'a dit bon tu
vas rester là maintenant va faire
l'amour ensemble je l'étape et j'ai tapé
il m'a foutu des j'ai fait je suis tombé
par terre j'ai perdu conscience et quand
je me suis réveillé il est en train de
pénétrer
c'était atroce pour moi parce que
j'avais jamais eu d'expérience sexuelle
c'était la première fois que j'en avais
tu es juillet griffé le dos je lui ai
dit d'arrêter
il n'a pas voulu je suis dit que c'était
pouces qui faisait que ça ressemble à
rien du tout s'en prendre à moi alors
qu'il y avait des faits qui cherchait
que ça j'essaie de savoir plus ou moins
quand même je prenais conscience
d'essayer de lui dire d'arrêter et la
continuer ma pénétrer il s'est arrêté
c'était comme un sauvage il était tout
en sueur à somain ça m'a dégoûté je suis
rentré chez moi
enfin j'ai été chez quelqu'un parce que
je suis pas rentré chez moi et là
guînes pas rentrer chez vous parce que
je me suis dit on comprendra pas on
n'arrivera pas à me dans l'état où
j'étais je savais qu'on n'arriverait pas
me faire remonter la pente j'étais
tellement tellement déprimé dans un état
atroce que j'ai préféré ne pas rentrer
chez moi c'est un garçon de quel âge 26
ans 26 27 ans et je n'avais pas porté
plainte pourquoi je suis pas les porter
plainte sur le coup parce que je me dis
va falloir que je raconte tout ce que
tout ce que cet homme avait fait m'avait
fait subir et je m'en sentais pas le
courage pas à pas à ce moment là je
fasse je voyais se sentait que ça
n'irait pas j'y arriverai pas pourquoi
avez vous accepté de nous recevoir
aujourd'hui pourquoi parce que je plaide
la cause de tous les fans de toutes les
femmes qui se taisent elle devrait pas
elle devrait passer raffin site afin
qu'on puisse faire quelque chose tous
ensemble si on punissait peut-être qu'on
arriverait quelque chose c'est sûr même
si ses hommes prennent la prison c'est
sûr que nous on n'oubliera jamais le mal
qui nous en fait mais disons ça pourrait
peut-être les aider les aider à s'en
sortir et aujourd'hui est ce que vous
sentez que vous avez évolué par rapport
à 7 ce que vous avez vécu ce jour-là
évolué et évoluent et oui parce que mon
mari je suis resté très longtemps je
songerai je n'aurai pas à me contacter
d'un homme ou même comme tous
sociétaires c'était impossible ou qui me
parlait des hommes s'étaient c'était
inutile pour moi c'était poussée des
sauvages coiffe sas avait pas d'autres
non bon maintenant je sens que ça va
mieux parce que mon entourage ment pas
mon entourage ne sais pas ils m'en
parlent comme si c'était une chose
normale alors au fond de moi même je me
dit écoute c'est quelque chose de normal
il faut pas que tu te re buts comme ça
il faut faire un effort de ton côté mon
cet effort je les fais bon je sens que
ça va mieux maintenant
mais c'est pas ça puis ce sera jamais ça
au fil des années j'oublierai c'est sûr
mais ce sera pas comme si j'étais une
flic avait une expérience sexuelle tout
à fait normal après ce témoignage voici
donc maintenant le texte que les députés
vont avoir à discuter à partir de demain
de lisburne pour la loi aujourd'hui le
viol est un crime commis simplement
content
une femme il faut qu'il y est contrainte
ou violences cette définition date du
second empire
aujourd'hui on va peut-être la changer
et le texte du projet de loi étend la
définition du viol et l'appliquent à
tout acte de pénétration sexuelle de
quelque nature qu'il soit commis ou
tenté sur tout être humain sans
distinction de sexe ni d'âge et bien
entendu sous la contrainte
toujours selon ce projet les peines
encourues resteraient les mêmes dix à
vingt ans de réclusion criminelle
cependant les sénateurs en 1978
demandait une réduction de la moitié de
ses peines et les associations
féministes avaient alors violemment
réagi
l'opposition souhaite pour sa part un
allègement des peines avec circonstances
aggravantes pour les mineurs et les
actes collectifs
enfin autre objet du débat la publicité
des procès pour viol il n'y aura huit
clos que si la victime le demande ce qui
devrait augmenter le nombre des
audiences publiques
oui pour être complet complet sur ce
sujet la vie pour conclure de madame
monique pelletier ministre de la
condition féminine qui était aujourd'hui
l'invité des centaines de viols chaque
année et pendant longtemps bien les
victimes n'auraient pas porté plainte
et pendant longtemps il faut le dire les
tribunaux n'accordait pas une importance
suffisante à ce qui est cette ce crime
intolérable alors les pratiques ont
évolué actuellement auprès prime le
fiole mais il est tout à fait utile il y
est un texte de loi qui précise et je
dirais disent clairement que ce que doit
être la répression et la dissuasion du
viol
la france défend l'europe affirme le
président de la république monsieur
giscard d'estaing dans une interview que
publiera demain le journal le figaro le
chef de l'état a tenu à mettre les
partenaires de la france devant leurs
responsabilités avant le sommet de
luxembourg
après avoir expliqué que si le problème
était de trouver simplement un moyen
d'aider la grande-bretagne à faire face
à une difficulté une solution équitable
peut être trouvé monsieur giscard
d'estaing a ajouté par contre que si au
contraire il s'agissait de modifier
durablement le système
financier de la communauté se s'y
intéresse tous les états qui doivent
dire clairement s'ils acceptent ou non
cette modification ce sont les propres
termes du chef de l'état la majorité des
français est d'accord avec la politique
du gouvernement en ce qui concerne le
problème palestinien et donc par voie de
conséquence vis-à-vis d'israël c'est ce
qui ressort d'un sondage effectué par la
sofres pour le compte des journaux de
province et dont le résultat constitue
donc une nouvelle donnée importante dans
la vie politique française
premier enseignement donc de ce sondage
50% des français sont d'accord avec la
politique du président de la république
avec ces trois éléments qui figurent
explicitement dans la question posée
l'autodétermination du peuple
palestinien
la participation de l'ol paie aux
négociations et la garantie des
frontières d'israël
il y à 17 % d'opposants on peut parler
donc d'un assez large consensus
et c'est bien sûr un motif de
satisfaction pour le gouvernement une
satisfaction qui sera peut être atténuée
par la deuxième constatation 66% des
personnes interrogées estiment que ce
qui a joué le plus dans la prise de
position française ce sont je cite les
considérations financières industrielles
et pétrolières 12% seulement pensent que
ce sont des considérations politiques
diplomatiques ou militaires
les français apparaissent réaliste c'est
le moins que l'on puisse dire
ils font passer les intérêts avant les
grands principes et les grands
sentiments
troisième élément la sympathie pour
israël a considérablement diminué depuis
quelques années
depuis 1976 elle est passée de 40 à 20%
la sympathie pour les pays arabes est
passée de 4 à 8%
mais ce qui frappe le plus c'est que
près de trois français sur quatre 72%
refuse de choisir entre les deux camps
où veulent choisir à la fois l'un et
l'autre les images personnelles des
messieurs sadate et begin ont sans doute
beaucoup joué dans cette évolution
et puis il ya aussi d'autres points plus
chaud à travers le globe les français en
tout cas apparaissent moins divisée est
moins passionné qu'on pouvait le penser
les troupes israéliennes vous
l'annonçait déjà hier soir ont établi
des positions dans le sud liban dans la
partie de territoire
jouxtant leur frontière avec le liban
est occupé par des milices chrétiennes
cette action est considérée comme une
riposte à l'attentât palestiniens en
israël au début de la semaine
pendant ce temps là à washington le
président égyptien sadate à termi
ces entretiens avec monsieur carter sur
le problème de l'autonomie palestinienne
rien n'a filtré comme il est convenu de
dire les un porte parole du président
américain a tout de même déclaré qui
n'existait pas de problèmes insolubles
et que tout serait fait pour obtenir un
accord d'ici à la date limite
10 26 mai prochain le premier ministre
israélien monsieur begin vous savez
sûrement déjà sera la semaine prochaine
à washington
au tchad les combats se poursuivent avec
moins d'intensité semble-t-il malgré
tout bien que les partisans du vice
président monsieur kamougué qui n'était
pas encore rentré dans le combat
viennent justement de s'y engager en se
rapprochant des faubourgs de la capitale
djamen et ce soir devant la commission
des affaires étrangères du parlement
français monsieur galets de ministre de
la coopération a répété que la france
n'avait pas du tout l'intention
d'intervenir dans ce conflit intérieur
au tchad la réduction des livraisons de
gaz algérien à la france est elle
réellement due à des raisons techniques
c'est ce qu'affirme le ministre algérien
du pétrole pour qui il n'a jamais été
question de suspendre livraison à la
france même en période de négociation
sur les prix de ce gaz algérien enfin
une annonce la visite de monsieur
gromyko le ministre des affaires
étrangères soviétique qui sera à paris
du 22 au 24 avril
la nouvelle n'est pas encore tout à fait
officiel le métro parisien est sale et
cela risque de durer un bon moment
encore en effet jusqu'à présent toutes
les négociations entre le personnel les
entreprises de nettoyage et leur
direction ont échoué
la grève a été même revoter aujourd'hui
le pire dans toute cette affaire c'est
que les grévistes semblent ne pas
trouver de véritables interlocuteurs
bernard marquié 18 jours sans un coup de
balai les 900 nettoyeur du métro
employés par 12 sociétés privées gagner
deux mille trois cent cinquante francs
par mois
ils en réclament 2800 les patrons sous
traitants se disent tenu par le budget
nettoyage de la ratp
les offres au maximum une augmentation
de 2,25 pour cent la ratp régie autonome
des transports parisiens affirment
qu'elle n'y peut rien elle sous traite
dans les limites de son budget des
grévistes 98 % d'immigrés tiennent bon
selon la cfdt
la situation est bloquée je maintiendrai
dit
fils il m'a puisque j'ai ma famille là
pour payer le loyer se nourrir je m'en
sors pas peux pas m'en sortir je
considère que c'est un travail pénible
pénible alors vous êtes en grève depuis
trois semaines dernier tombe plus votre
vie et quelle est la situation
maintenant comment faites-vous et est ce
que vous pensez pouvoir tenir longtemps
oui on pense et puis on attend décidé on
a décidé de continuer jusqu'au bout
quelles que soient la durée jusqu'à que
ça aboutisse nos revendications soient
satisfaites
malgré l'amoncellement des immondices
les usagers du métro font bonne figure
mais pour l'hygiène minimum et la
sécurité incendie la limite est atteinte
avec les nettoyeurs du métro en grève
les grévistes placent leurs espoirs dans
la mairie de paris qui acceptera
peut-être de provoquer une réunion à
trois employeurs syndicats ratp en
dernier ressort et comme d'habitude la
solution dépendra des pouvoirs publics
hier soir les députés ont adopté le
volet économique du projet de loi
d'orientation agricole et cet après midi
le débat tel article sur le statut
professionnel des femmes d'agriculteurs
700 mille femmes sont concernées c'est
seulement fin avril que cette loi
devrait probablement être adoptée après
son passage devant les sénateurs la
marée noire du tanio suite au rendez
vous manqués des bretons à paris une
délégation d'élus du finistère et des
côtes du nord sera reçue le 23 avril par
monsieur giscard d'estaing parallèlement
le comité d'étude et de liaison des
intérêts bretons proteste lui contre le
colmatage de l'épave du tanio annoncé
hier par le ministre des transports
monsieur le colmatage qui
n'interviendrait pas avant cinq mois
alors que c'est en ce moment que les
conditions sont les plus favorables pour
le renflouement affaires de breuil
monsieur georges fillioud du parti
socialiste souhaite que le parlement se
prononce sur la ce qu'il appelle la mise
en accusation de monsieur michel
poniatowski le député socialiste estime
que l'ancien ministre de l'intérieur
était dans l'illégalité en violant le
secret de l'instruction
au cours d'une conférence de presse cinq
jours après l'assassinât du prince de
breuil conférence de presse vous en
souvenez sans doute dans laquelle
monsieur poniatowski avait affirmé que
l' affaire était pratiquement
de lui sport football je ne reviens pas
sur la victoire de nantes hier soir 2-1
sur valence
vous l'avez vu en direct sur antenne 2
voici plutôt les plus belles phases de
jeu des autres rencontres de coupe
d'europe commenté par notre spécialiste
thierry roland la 25e finale de la coupe
d'europe des clubs champions aura lieu
le 21 mai prochain à madrid le real
aimerait bien y participer
et pour cela les madrilènes en maillot
blanc à l'occasion de ce match aller des
demi-finales ont battu le tambour de
keegan par 2 à 0 deux buts réussis par
l'avant-centre santillana sur des
grossières erreurs de la défense ouest
allemand
le match retour dans quinze jours à
hambourg promet d'être chaud d'autant
plus que kevin keegan ne sais pas trop
montré sur la pelouse de santiago
bernabeu
il en sera tout autrement à n'en pas
douter au vol parc stadiers pendant ce
temps nottingham forest battait l'ajax
d'amsterdam également par 2 à 0 en coupe
d'europe des vainqueurs de coupes
à londres arsenal et juventus se sont
livrés une belle bataille
une erreur de défense un penalty
indiscutable sifflé par l'excellent
arbitre néerlandais monsieur corbin
penalty tiré par antonio cabrini
l'arrière de la jupe repoussé par jenny
numéro free par cabrini et la juventus
mène par 1 à 0
quand on sait ce que veut dire une
équipe italienne qui mène 1-0 à
l'extérieur on n'est pas étonné de voir
le carton rouge attribué à tardelli qui
ne jouera ni le match retour ni une
finale éventuelle pourquoi pas contre
nantes
égalisation de la tête non pas stapleton
mais bettega contre son camp mais c'est
la juve qui a fait la bonne affaire et
nantes nantes que nous allons revoir
battre valence seulement par 2 à 1
car le score aurait dû être plus sévère
un coup franc de michel
on croit que baroncelli à marquer or
c'est arias qui a marqué contre son camp
1 à 0 pour les nantais qui concéderont
l'égalisation à ce phénomène du but qui
est mario kempès l'argentin mais qui
auront les ressources nerveuse pour
marquer à dix minutes de la fin un but
qui finalement vaut de l'or sur ce
centre de bossis transformé par bruno
baron chez lui les nantais iront à
valence avec un but d'avant oui je
pensais qu'on n'aurait pas le temps de
revoir ces images de nantes et bien on a
quand même voulu vous faire plaisir
il y avait un tiercé aujourd'hui pour
gagner il fallait jouer le 9 le 4 et le
7 pirette bresse avait donné dans l'or
c'est tiercé en 5 chevaux voici les
rapports bravo pirette 822 francs 5 ans
dans le désordre ou dans un ordre
différent comme disait turfiste 164
francs 50 toujours pour femmes francs et
puis si on en est aux jeux il ya aussi
aux jeux de hasard il ya le loto ce soir
pour gagner il fallait jouer le 5 le 12
le 41 45 47 numéro complémentaire 10
voilà maintenant la météo avec monsieur
laurent broomhead en personne
écoutez va faire beau c'est une bonne
nouvelle en effet depuis plusieurs jours
le baromètre est au beau fixe mais
l'anticyclone autres moyens la zone de
beau temps était plutôt sur l'ouest du
pays alors le vent coulin sur l'est
donnant à la fois de la fraîcheur et
même de la froidure et puis des nuages
puis l'anticyclone se décaler vers l'est
s'il est maintenant bien centré sur la
france et pourquoi il y aura nettement
plus de soleil demain partout encore
quelques passages nuageux dans le
nord-est
et puis quelques averses possibles en
corse mais rien de trop grave
du beau temps pratiquement partout après
toutefois la brume matinale
principalement dans le centre de
l'aquitaine aux régions rhône alpes le
températures encore très fraîche dans
ces régions du centre le matin quelques
gelées jusqu'à -1 degrés mais ensuite
des températures qui meurent montrant
beaucoup plus haute les jours précédents
dans la journée ça c'est pour vendredi
samedi maintenant le même temps continue
très beau températures nettement plus
chaud de l'après-midi et du soleil à peu
près par tous les états y prédominante
toutefois pas t'aider samedi soir comme
l'anticyclone continuera de se déplacer
vers l'est
il est normal que les puis reviennent
par l'ouest en l'occurrence le sud ouest
et à partir de samedi soir les nuages
reviendront c'est en fait dimanche que
sur une partie sud ouest du pays il fera
plus nuageux avec quelques averses
orageuses en particulier en aquitaine
partout ailleurs au contraire surtout
une grande moitié ouest est pardon du
pays
il devrait faire beau et surtout
nettement plus chaud avec de l'air qui
vient du site les bonnes nouvelles
merci laurent ou fait confiance vous
nous aviez pas menti la semaine dernière
je n'ai vérifier moi-même pour terminer
durant deux mois
charles aznavour va se produire à
l'olympia parmi les nouveautés de ce
tour de chant une création qui s'adresse
tout particulièrement aux sourds et aux
malentendants
pour accompagner cette chanson charles
aznavour a appris le langage gestuel
comme on dit avec mademoiselle joël le
lunel à nieppe ce qui est notre
spécialiste ici antenne 2 hier il a
interprété cette chanson en avant
première pour notre émission c'est la
vie vous propose de voir ou de revoir un
extrait de cette émission
remise pour te parler
je me manquer
moyen
trouvant près de toi comme en terre
étrangère ne pouvant me servir aucun
vocabulaire
à mon tour j'ai appris de langage
tuerie un peu de moi quand tu vois les
efforts car je suis maladroit et fait
souvent des gardes
je n'ai jamais été très fort en
orthographe
mais j'ai tant ajouté
et je t'aime aussi fort
mon amour
non à vous
voilà dernier journal ce soir présenté
par et avec tout ce sera le dernier
rendez vous avec l'information puis
demain antenne 2010 avec un emmy en
invité monsieur jean malaurie ethnologue
je vous souhaite une excellente soirée
sur antenne 2 et on se retrouve demain
soir à 20 heures
si vous le voulez bien bonsoir